well they know leave that yeah don't
attach other feet ah no no no you don't
understand what happened god damn it you
don't understand it's amazing cuz I
don't mess with the nahban I know you're
not doing it intentionally but it feels
like you are it feels like you are what
would happen put hands on the backs nubs
the so he's got hands in the front and
hands in the back to go large the hands
yeah make that make the hands a bit
bigger bigger bigger bigger who's gonna
be a great few from the back and the
front all right we ready to name the bad
boy what if we change it to the capstan
nipples or something get the paint said
should we change the color again or I
think it's color like works oh my god
this color works
wait let Nate well let Nate Nate over
here Nate let Nate name him okay
way to get the name Wade you get to name
this one I was gonna say I know one I
got one line up I got if you got one
it's more like who but people will get
it right hey hey you can make a chewy or
something no wait no no if we're doing
that oh hello everybody my name is Marta
bar and welcome back to spore we just
got done with our new creature give that
give a bad boy has been there that bad
boy oh yeah oh yeah it's got like one of
those incognito camouflage not really
behind me face is actually is like look
here the backgrounds like looks like a
body like from the back that's fine
that's exactly what I was just saying
anyway please view
I forgot there was a loading screen yeah
those really thin muscular legs it's all
because of counterbalancing okay get in
there and show the world that's your
home turn around take over the world
you're sassy bastards no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no right you
just changed your objective went wrong
with you why is it fire
fine yeah item you got this you got this
Jessica 700 your health is down yeah
your dad yeah oh
then you listen to what i'ma do oh
really
oh really ah
hey guys unfortunately our game crashed
and on top of that we didn't save at all
so I just had to play for 45 minutes
back to the point where we were it went
way faster than what Tyler was doing
isn't that right Tyler yes yes was doing
that too and it crashed again while I
was replaying so we're gonna end this
episode here because we were so stressed
and angry we got some tea so cheers to
you guys out there hope you're having a
lovely day we hope you're enjoying this
series there's only gonna be a few more
episodes but we'll keep them coming
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always
you have beautiful eyes